good morning modern stutters it's a
balmy 19 degrees out this morning
gotta love winter speaking of winter we
need to prep our chicken coop for winter
let's get that finished this morning I'm
gonna go over to one of the tents and
pick out the chicken wire believe and
hope I have a roll of chicken wire in
here yes I do I'm not super worried
about keeping critters out of this part
of the chicken run this will be the
chicken run except they'll be in here
during the day so I'm not too concerned
about predators during the day accreta
me locked up at night in New York City
that's predator proof so what I want to
do today is make it so the chickens stay
in and they can't get out
fourme up here in northern New Hampshire
the winter chicken coop is more about
function how do we get the coop to
function well and do what we needed to
do throughout the winter where we don't
have to spend a lot of the money run
electricity for heat lives and further
water is how do we get the chickens to
thrive in the normal conditions without
having to baby them we don't want to
have to do that here
[Applause]
I found the tarps that cover lumber
piles at the lumber yard where they last
a while so they have a white site and a
black side so depending on what purpose
you use it for you might want to have
different sides out and so for our one
of our shooting tractors that the
chickens are in the summertime we have
the white reflect the Sun this being a
winter chicken coop I'm going to put the
black out so it attracts the Sun it
should help heat up the green
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's my mistake I thought this tarp
was 16 feet long
only a 12-footer man oh well I'll use it
for now
[Applause]
[Music]
well that's definitely a disappointment
I thought all the tops I had were 16
feet long I'm going to go buy two new
ones now one for the chicken coop and
one for the pigs not doing that today we
don't have time for that but let's let
the chickens out feed them let's go give
the pig some more hay it's gonna be fun
I bet who else is gonna like this hot
water outdoors Beckett it's going to be
all the animals this winter they'll be
able to have hot water to drink
[Applause]
I like putting the grain right down
topper where I want the animals to
scratch check through and eat we want to
start turning all this hay for us so
it's why we're feeding them right here
we want to encourage that kind of
behavior in our animals
I'm hoping this keeps them in if it does
we can bring the Icelandic chickens in
over to the winter chicken coop I bet
they'll love being able to be the bigger
flock and stay warmer when it gets
colder Oh mr. Biggs you quiet this
morning
oh it's Andy going after you how's the
warm water
let's go give the pig some water then
we'll bring up over some fresh hay
[Music]
they're still sleeping now coming out to
this site is never gonna get old good
morning girls
buried in that hay staying warm you know
bring in see if we can show you a
pursuit oh she's in there somewhere
oh there's the other schnauzer good
morning come on and there you are oh you
look like happy pigs you know once a
nice warm water yeah then I'll bring you
some more hey took me a second to find
their dish I was hoping it wasn't back
in the tote
all right Copa it's just a nice warm
water out here for them
they're a lot more friendly now not
coppa getting to know us already
don't worry prosciutto you don't need to
get up I'm gonna go get the hey stay
here and keep an eye on the pigs for me
blowing bubbles over there you can eat
it you can play in it whatever you want
to do okay hello camera well I wasn't
get everything done that I want you
that's all right it was still a good day
the pigs are settling in nicely all the
animals are doing great in the cold
weather we're getting used to it too
we're enjoying a nice fresh smoked bacon
we have in the house all the great food
we put up throughout the season now we
get to sit back and enjoy that and just
have fun
thankful for the year
great pigs
and we're looking forward to the future
thanks for liking commenting and
subscribing I'll see you right back here
tomorrow at Alumni egg there's a guide
to modern homesteading self-sufficiency
and freedom
[Music]
[Applause]